bonsoir pour obtenir le 22 à asnières
comme le racontait fernand raynaud il ne
faut plus appeler new york il ya
longtemps d'ailleurs il ya déjà un petit
moment
fini aussi le temps où le où l'on se
taper sur les cuisses quand la france du
général de gaulle décidé de construire
des ordinateurs et puis un jour
peut-être on ne regardera plus avec un
air béat les japonais les américains
avec leurs gadgets vous avec qui
consiste à relier un téléphone et un
téléviseur pour donner des informations
bientôt nous aurons ça aussi chez nous
c'est la télématique voilà les trois
domaines traités ce matin au conseil des
ministres pour marquer encore une fois
la volonté du gouvernement non seulement
de rattraper son retard mais d'être dans
les tous premiers dans le développement
des activités nouvelles grâce à une
technologie en pointe et bien maîtrisé
avec activité nouvelle qui conformément
aux voeux de monsieur giscard d'estaing
sont économes en énergie ça c'est
important et puis créatrice d'emplois
nouveaux cela aussi c'est très important
ainsi pour le téléphone alors que nous
étions au dernier rang des pays
européens
en 1974 le retard doit être comblé
totalement en 1982 mais déjà ça va
beaucoup mieux
il y avait douze lignes téléphoniques
pour 100 habitants il ya cinq ans il y
en a aujourd'hui 25
il y avait six millions d'abonnés à peu
près en 74 13 millions aujourd'hui plus
de 19 millions dans trois ans cet effort
a permis le développement d'une
industrie des télécommunications qui se
situe parmi les plus avancées a dit le
secrétaire d'état aux ptt norbert segard
et puis qui est aussi exportatrices
l'industrie informatique française est
elle aussi en plein essor on dit qu'elle
est créatrice d'emplois un niveau élevé
malheureusement et ça ça n'est pas dit
dans le communiqué du conseil des
ministres
on manque d'ingénieurs et d'un fin
informaticiens c'est peut-être pour cela
qu'un important programme d'initiation
et de formation à l'informatique dans
les collèges lycées et universités a été
décidée dès le mois d'octobre prochain
centre emplissez recevront des micro
ordinateurs
enfin il ya donc la télématique ce mot
barbare parce que nous
à propos duquel michel chevalet va nous
donner l'éclairage nécessaire la
télématique vous savez et bien c'est le
mariage entre le téléphone la télévision
et l'ordinateur et un mariage finalement
très réussie puisque déjà et bien on
voit apparaître des enfants les nouveau
nés alors les voici
alors tout d'abord nous sommes à la
maison nous sommes chez nous et bien
chez nous le cadran téléphonique va être
remplacé et voyez par ce clavier à
touches et à partir de 1981 3 millions
de postes comme celui ci seront
installés chez les abonnés ensuite et
bien toujours la maison il va y avoir et
il est déjà en service seront présentés
l'annuaire électronique en quelque sorte
deux parties premièrement vous voyez un
écran de télévision sur lequel
s'affichent les renseignements que l'on
trouve habituellement valmer et puis un
clavier pour l'interroger à la une
précision à partir de 1980 les deux cent
cinquante mille abonnés d'ille et
vilaine et bien posséderont un annuaire
téléphonique qui sera mis gratuitement à
leur disposition une variante également
de ce système
c'est le terreau est elle cette fois ci
c'est l'écran de votre téléviseur relié
à un clavier spécial et sur l'écran doté
de viseur apparaîtront différents
renseignements comme par exemple si vous
aimez la bourse les cours de la bourse
ou bien les horreurs de chemin de fer ou
bien les programmes des spectacles
toujours à la maison nous aurons un
appareil semblable à celui ci c'est un
télécopieur autrement dit mais vous
voyez en ce moment je suis en train
d'acheminer ni plus ni moins qu'un
document c'est à dire une lettre un
correspondant située à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de distance
et c'est en quelque sorte la
démocratisation et télécopie puisque l
appareil bien vous sera proposé pour
2000 francs c'est en quelque sorte et
bien le courrier électronique mais le
plus intéressant peut-être c'est à dire
ici au niveau du bureau de poste au
niveau du guichet alors vous imaginez
que nous sommes dans un bureau de poste
voilà en face de madame il y à un
terminal d'ordinateurs elle procède en
direct avec l'ordinateur les opérations
s'est dit qu'en ce moment je lui ai
demandé sur mon livret de caisse
d'epargne d'effectuer un retrait de 2000
francs et brouillé que son livre est il
y as en bas une piste magnétique sur
lequel sont portés des renseignements et
notamment la position de mon compte
vous continuez madame elle interroge
donc l'ordinateur l'ordinateur dit que
l'on peut
et qu est ce retrait et regardez bien la
suite extrêmement intéressante
le document est avalée immédiatement en
direct et bien mon compte en quelque
sorte est mise à jour et lloris et alors
ensuite eh bien on peut procéder
voilà même type d'opération avec vous le
savez les chèques postaux je vous
signale qu'à nantes déjà des bureaux
sont équipés avec ce système qu'à la fin
du mois
l'opération démarrera à paris et qu'en
dix mille bureaux de poste seront ainsi
équipés voilà donc la grande révolution
de la télématique dans le domaine des
ptt voyait une révolution qui avance à
grands pas